[Musique]
daniel craig le héros du dernier james
bond mourir peux t'attendre reçoit en
effet son étoile sur le fameux hollywood
book of fame c'est à los angeles sa
plaque est placé à côté de celle de
roger moore autre célèbre acteur qui a
prêté ses traits à 0,07 de 1973 à 1985
est elle craque et de quatrième agent
bond à recevoir tél c'est un peu surfait
de mettre la veste de la couleur de ses
yeux à ses très jolies danses et l'asie
mais voilà
et surtout il n'avait pas son étoile
déjà non il est pas son étoile et en
plus à l'issue de la cérémonie il a
déclaré que c'était un honneur absolue
pour lui d'être piétiné à hollywood à ce
joli monde machiste donc
s'arrêter là mike vous aussi ça vous
fait frétiller les orteils c'est quoi
une sortie
si vous appelez oui
c'est ça et donc sur les pieds vous
aussi vous prenez votre pied
à pied sont moches c'est le visage d'un
homme qui vient de réussir un exploit
unique
au coeur de l'himalaya le manaslu plus
de 8000 mètres d'altitude
qu'il a gravi à la force des bras
rostam nabil f est un russe de 29 ans
amputé des deux jambes
une équipe de plusieurs chaires paf l'a
assistée pour cette ascension est aidée
pour les passages les plus délicats
madame le pen c'est pas vous qui avez
besoin des annonces ça va bien merci
voyez
je suis chez le personnel peuple
français j'essaie de sauver le mannequin
qui soumet soudainement face après
alors d'accord non gentil mais
l'entraînement il convient de mettre
justement cette minute ça permet de
maintenir pour un mois de production il
y avait partie électoralistes comme par
exemple les insoumis qui surf justement
sur ce communautarisme
moi ce que je vais répondre moi j'aime
permettent de faire mais je sais c'est
insupportable cherhal supporter comme
j'ai entendu une équité bancaires sabric
vous est insupportable et on essaie de
péter la gueule non pelata avec avec un
débatteur jeu débat
est-ce que vous pouvez
vous parler tout le temps sur tout le
monde donc soyez gentils chacun son tour
non mais non restez avec nous vous avez
essentiel et on peut pas finir une
phrase donc non plus qu'est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas des chiffres entre 150 et
sert au delà des espoirs oui ça fait
combien américaine vous connaissez pas
le prix mais je sais pas
mais non sa fiche est raide et
maintenant on fait déjà chez très se
faire un élevage grande écoute harold
nous tirons sillonner la france ensemble
générique wallach de nos collectionneurs
si vous aviez eu une compagne de voyage
aussi bavarde mais là je n'ai rien volé
t1 soit vu débouter la semaine où on
apprend qu'il ya onze mille 300
milliards d'euros qu'on sait tout fait
voler à l'échelle mondiale par des gens
qu'ils soient blancs noirs ou de la
couleur je m'en fiche chorale et thierry
garrido nous on part m
eric naulleau j'ai pas parlé de piles
des normes et celeron je veux bien vous
parliez mais le sujet la localisation ce
que je dis non c'est pas beau alain
jouhanneau syrien l'ancien directeur
général du fmi acceptent notre
invitation
nous recevons ce contrat
pour 45 minutes de discours il faut
débourser 70 mille euros hors taxes
auxquels il faut ajouter les billets
d'avion en business class sur la
compagnie de son choix
deux nuits en chambre suite dans un
hôtel là aussi de son choix le slip au
ni ni qu il y aurait pu être plus
parfait mais dans un contexte inhabituel
les pieds dans l'herbe je trouve que je
me suis plutôt bien
dépatouiller je suis plutôt content de
mon seul et j'espère que mes recruter
cyril vont l'apprécier tout au toc -
quelle partie d'un animal de boucherie
déguster vous si vous mangez des rognons
blancs
les reins
[Musique]
des glandes
ça s'appelle les testicules a vraiment
navrant à cette heure-là grande écoute
ont dit les testicules l'institut et bon
appétit bien sûr talent heaslip comme ça
toi exactement nagra après 40 ans même
bien voir du confort ville tél
c'est réaliste c'est un beau slip
bien-être mais apprend bien blanc voilà
bien longueur d'onde
je suis même vous
soyez fiers de votre couleur blanche
parce que ça c'est plus important ça
c'est plus important que de combattre ne
dis jamais jamais entendu et il est pas
de la map et lé pandora paper chasse est
plus important que tout était un sujet
d'un service info je n'ai jamais vu ça
50% au sujet records du monde battus et
si c'était une discipline olympique on
aurait une médaille d'or vous aurez beau
zapper sur toutes les chaînes mesdames
et messieurs allez-y si vous voulez vous
ne trouverez jamais des moments de télé
comme celui ci est ce que c'est validé
par le chas à philippe je valide s'il
fait la chaîne bon drôle ça
il faut la crypte et le singe c'est à
peu près pas pas toute l'année
tu touches et papa le sable c'est un
petit peu comme la barbe à papa
ensuite on a l'eau blanc ça aussi c'est
un peu comme pas peur aller parce que
transit
ça me fait mal la poste andro la
hi hi
les gens la maison peuvent très bien
pour qu'il vous relève
pour qui
l'accusée maurice mann d'accord donc
quand je dis que
la ligue a rejeté dans son prêche on
voit que vous avez définies
voilà c'est ma meilleure comédie c'est
pas vous tenez des propos vous parlera
quand l'idée de s'en prendre à des
personnes je suis véronique j'ai 61 ans
et je suis une ancienne députée j'ai été
député écologiste de 2012 à 2017 il est
nécessaire de voir au delà de ce critère
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé
notamment on se suffit mais qui sait
qu'il suffit d'un moment j'ai pas une
poule 1 c'est bon
j'ai commencé la pâtisserie à un moment
où ma vie et pas très drôle parce que je
venais perd des élections mes joies mes
rêves soutient péter mes joies mes rêves
sont pétés va enfin cette émission je
pense qu'on a fait le tour
tu t'en vas y je vois mes rêves sont
pétés l'éolienne de 200 m dos comme tu
dis on peut aller jusqu'à 1500 tonnes de
béton à chaque pays 70 à 80 tonnes de
ferraille quand tu sais que ces trucs là
personne c'est les recycler en donc ça
veut dire que quand tu vas au tour de
nantes il ya des chants complet de pales
d'éoliennes
les seules façons qu'ont l'adversité
pour l'instant c'était broyer des bruits
dans les cimenteries fait partie de
cette génération on la pourrit la
planète le plus simplement du monde
situe manille t elle a rien à faire sur
cette planète
[Rires]